hello everyone
and of course welcome back to the road
to 2000 as always my name is caleb denby
and i will be your driver
on this journey and tonight it's going
to be a pretty special episode it's
always a special occasion
when the world champion doesn't win a
tournament and it looks like that's
going to be the case
in this year's feed a world cup so we
talked about some
interesting upsets and some turbulent
games going on
at the world cup last week but tonight i
want to focus on magnus carlson's game
in particular and especially these two
games where we saw
sort of magnus breaking against some up
and coming players
who i mean they're not necessarily up
and coming but they are
younger than the current world champ and
two top contenders
for quote unquote the future of chess
so i want to start with this game but
between andre
essepenko and magnus carlson so esapenko
is a young russian player
who is um he's been in the 2700s for
some time now
and he was really showing his stuff
against magnus they split in the
classical portion
and then we actually saw essepenko draw
first blood against magnus
in the rapid portion and that's the game
that i want to look at first today
so let's start here estepanco starts
with e4
we get e5 knight f3
knight c6 bishop c4
and the joko piano in the italian
so magnus or sorry acepenko starts with
c3 we get knight f6
and rather than the more concrete
variations with d4
esopenko plays the joko pianissimo so
the quietest game
you can imagine so of course this is one
of the oldest
openings in chess and there's very
little left sort of
untested or at least that's what what
they used to think
these days this is becoming more and
more common at the top
level i think in part because they're
sick of playing
berlins all day long so more players are
going for the italian
rather than the royal lopez and also
because
they somehow are sort of discovering
that black might actually have some
issues
i know there's been a lot of discussion
over the queen side in particular
in these openings white is taking queen
side space a little bit earlier than
they used to
and very often is able to make good use
of it
but for the moment let's continue here
magnus plays d6
white castles and then magnus picks this
move
h6 now i am by no means the foremost
expert in
the italian but h6 does feel a little
bit early
it seems as though this is not an
uncommon move by any stretch
but there's not too much point in
playing it right away it's not as if
after castles
black is very terrified of this move
bishop g5
in fact black tends to be doing pretty
well here after
h6 g5 and sort of expanding on the
king's side
with that being said maybe there was
something magnus didn't like about
allowing bishop g5
and so he chose this move h6 first
instead
now it doesn't ruin anything but it's
just sort of the the first move where
uh magnus is taking the game away
from the main main main variations you
have to do quite a few of these sort of
offbeat moves to to actually achieve
that in the italian though
let's continue on though we get rookie
one by essenpenko
castles by black now h3 by white
is is also very normal especially
considering this move h6 has been played
occasionally you'll you'll see some um
some king side garbage like knight h2 to
g4
um just to soften up the king's sight
but that that would come much much later
in the game
uh and of course this also has the nice
idea of preventing moves like bishop g4
or even uh knight g4 taking advantage of
the fact that this rook
is no longer on the f1 square
okay continuing now magnus plays this
move
bishop back to b6 and this one
is is pretty strange to me i wasn't
really familiar with this
move order in the italian
um so why do you think magnus is playing
this move
bishop b6 any italian uh
aficionados in the class today who knows
what's up with this move
what's magnus getting at here
uh okay that would be news to me eric in
the class
says that he thinks magus might be
playing for
c5 um yeah that would be a new idea to
me that's not
the answer that that i came up with
personally
but uh but fair enough maybe some weird
c5 idea in some positions but i
i have my doubts to be honest um
any other days yeah brian
i'm guessing
yeah so not only in how to respond to
d4 you know dropping the bishop back so
d4 doesn't come with tempo
uh is is potentially a an important idea
although i'm not certain that white
should really be playing d4 here
uh anyways it's a little bit early to be
doing it even though black has wasted
some time with h6
i think this would lead to
simplifications that
tend to favor tend to favor black right
now black is always going to have this
idea
and after rookie 8 you may have some
difficulties organizing your pieces
especially considering the pressure on
the e4 pawn
for example if you play knight bd2 after
rookie 8
you would potentially like to bring this
knight to f1 uh to g3
but you might not have the luxury of
doing that quite so easily and also
okay knight d2 i'm just hanging my d4
pawn so
that's a little bit ridiculous but uh
the point stands
that you're not so comfortable with your
e4 pawn yet to be playing d4
uh and that can often be the problem in
these italians in order to play a move
like d4
you have to be ready on on both d4 and
the e4 squares
um personally what i think it is is you
know number one
it probably doesn't matter that much if
you play a move like a6 or a5 or bishop
b6 first
and number two i think that potentially
magnus was
less than happy with um the positions
that we've been seeing maybe not b4
right away
but the positions we've been seeing
where white is taking all this extra
space
on the queen's side so so quickly and
easily
this is one of the big new ideas in in
the italian it's not totally new
but this is where they've been testing a
little bit they take all the space on
the queen side and black has some
problems
so i think number one magnus was trying
to sort of preempt these ideas
like b4 and number two if
you know black got a little bit or white
got a little bit ambitious and played b4
right away
um black would be very ready with
variations like this when uh yes
white has all this extra space but we'll
see that
there's an important difference here
than with what happens
in the game you know white has extra
space here but there's really no way to
use it there's no way to break the
position open
on the queen side and uh historically
black has been able to
equalize pretty comfortably with an
eventual d5
in these positions uh but let's continue
on let's continue on so knight d2
knight e7 is how we continue here and
now after a4
black plays this move c6
so magnus is preventing this idea with a
of a5
uh which of course you know this is
always the common threat in the italian
a5 and b4
trapping the bishop so c6 instead
um but i think here magnus is already
starting to go
uh just a little bit wrong uh in his
opening
prep so you know it's it's joko pianismo
it's not that easy to be significantly
worse with black
but uh and i don't think black is by any
means significantly worse here
but it does start to get tricky to play
over the next few moves
so now that we've played c6 and
h6 white decides it is time to break
through with d4
why can we play d4 here when we didn't
want to a few moves ago
well it's because black gave up a lot of
pressure on white's central pawns
in order to reorganize the pieces we no
longer have this knight threatening d4
and the rook is a couple tempe away from
hitting e4
um black continues out now with knight
to g6
we see bishop back to f1 rookie eights
and then uh essie pengo organizes
organizes his pieces
with queen to c2 uh
and now we see magnus continue with
bishop to c7
and i want to stop here because this is
really where esipenko
uh takes at least a psychological
advantage if not
uh not a an actual advantage according
to a computer
so black just plays bishop c7 and this
seems to be magnus's big plan he's
rerouting the bishop back to c7
without spending any time on a6 or a5 on
the queen's side
so first let's try to figure out you
know what is magnus's idea
why is he putting this bishop back on c7
why this diagonal
rather than this diagonal
to pressure h2 says the the youtube chat
i'm not so sure that's that's the reason
there's there's a lot of stuff in the
way here right
um so yeah niels
in the chat also says to protect e5 so
why is protecting e5 relevant here
what's the big move that that black is
trying to play
d5 right so as long as white has this
pawn duo in the center
and black doesn't then uh white is going
to have a little bit of extra central
space
and can potentially claim one day that
this is going to be
some kind of kind of advantage i have
more space my pieces can move a little
bit more freely
so i have an advantage so what magnus is
trying to do
is uh if we get some nothing move by
white
uh magnus is trying to play d5 with now
the support
of the c7 bishop on the e5 pawn
so why is this bishop important well
because whenever you play d5
again you have to be comfortable with
both of these squares
and after something like takes
um now we would have three pieces
attacking e5 and so we need the bishop
for backup
to uh to make sure we're defending this
this square enough
uh so that's why bishop c7 so now the
challenge as essie penko
is you know that magnus is trying to
basically just totally equalize
with the move d5 if black can
successfully play d5
in the italians generally it's just
totally equal like unless white gets
some
some dynamic advantage so how do you
want to play
against this idea of d5
and i guess it is important to note um i
sort of lied to you there
black probably isn't playing d5 right
away because after takes
it's not super clear um what the best
way to recapture on d5 is
for uh for black um in fact
black probably wants to take d5 with the
bishop so magnus is likely going to be
supporting this move with bishop e6
before playing d5 so you basically have
two tempi
to uh to figure out what to do you know
d5 isn't super strong yet
because uh black has no good way to
recapture but after bishop b6
d5 is going to be coming
uh
okay so d5 for for white would be an
idea
but i'm not certain if we can we can
make that work and in fact uh
it might might be helping black more
than more than we want here for example
you know even if we weren't hanging upon
with d5 right now let's say we tried to
prepare it or something
well black is going to take on d4 the
second we play this move
and now his own pieces are going to be
able to to enter the fray
so it's uh not not the most common idea
here
in fact i was kind of scrubbing through
the database to find similar games
and i couldn't really couldn't really
find one that features this idea
um at least in a position that looks
like this
queen b3 okay what's the point to stop
bishop b6 i guess
um yeah potentially yeah
uh but i mean we we literally just
played this move queen c2
to defend our e4 pawn um
yeah okay all right maybe maybe not
though maybe we don't want to waste
quite so much time
i'm also not convinced you can take this
pawn in
many lines but okay black can play a
little bit more slowly something like
queen e7
and just continue continue improving the
pieces
okay so queen b3 let's let's say queen
e7 and you're saying d5 here yeah
yeah i'm i'm not so sure i think uh
takes
takes is is this so good for blood for
white
i don't know i don't know
okay all right eric's taking my free
pawn um
i'm gonna come out here 96.
okay i mean how is your queen not
trapped what kind of joke is this
okay maybe i miss playing this maybe i'm
just playing this
let's say bishop back to c6 or b6
all right eric is causing me too much
trouble
all right let's think here for a second
let's think here
take take you really you really just
want to get away with this huh
okay let's let's all right i i flinch
first i'll go rook b8
you know the more i'm looking at it the
less i like it i think i just want to
play
bishop e6 here and go for something
concrete
all right isn't your queen kind of
trapped queen a63
oh okay all right i have to cheat eric's
too good at chess i have to cheat
so what's wrong with queen b3 let's find
out
yeah nothing nothing is wrong with queen
b3 um black can play something like a5
though and go back to uh to normal play
on
on the queen side yeah i don't know the
queen just doesn't really feel like it
belongs here it's putting on some
pressure
but yeah the problem with d5 is okay
there you go that's that's the problem
with d5 nice
it just gives too many squares it
doesn't feel right to be giving away all
these
all these squares right that's sort of
the point of the pawn on c6 as well
um okay so something
better than queen b3 so i'm just going
to kind of give it away here
um very very often
who what can i make yeah go ahead brian
do you take e5 so d takes dtx5 is
definitely an important idea
in the position for white uh and i think
if black were to take back with the pawn
then uh i think white would be pretty
happy here
um this pawn is sort of in the way of
all of black's pieces
but the problem with it immediately is i
think black is is going to be trying to
take back with the knight
and the point now is we're sort of
revealing some pressure here
on the e file but
knight takes and f4 too much yeah
so this is super scary opening this
diagonal it's always scary
um i don't know where you want to go but
okay even here like i have some very
very silly ideas but
uh let's just say rookie eight and uh
i'm not so sure that
you know this this e5 idea is
is sort of what uh the direction that
that white should be headed
um so what essie funko does is he
takes the the slower gm approach so
rather than
uh some direct idea where he's like okay
d5 is impossible now
what he does is he tries to prepare his
pieces for the opening of the position
right and that's um that's what a lot of
these italian games are all about at
these super high levels
they simply want to make their pieces as
good as possible
to prepare them for the break so what
white piece
isn't really in the game right now well
it's this bishop on c1
so what essie penco does is he kind of
takes advantage of magnus's lack of this
a5 move
and he takes this opportunity to play b4
um magnus now does play bishop e6
getting ready for d5
and now scpenko plays bishop b2
so what's the point well the point is
now if
black plays d5 white actually has
numerous moves here that start to make
his position make a whole lot of sense
for example yes you have to calculate
all these captures
as magnus carlsen but not only do you
have to calculate those we have to
calculate
c4 as well and i get the feeling this is
the kind of thing
that uh was giving magnus some pause uh
in the game
yeah you know all pawns to the fourth
rank right and
what's the point of this move well the
point is if you play some
some you know sort of laissez-faire pawn
capture
i'm going to take back on e5 and things
are getting very very difficult for you
on this diagonal you definitely don't
want to allow takes takes
because your king's side is just going
to get totally shattered
and you can't really get away with
just playing something like knight d7
here because i'm just going to take back
and not super clear if you're
immediately going to get this pawn back
on on e5 or not not super clear
especially for a rapid game
um and beyond that if you think you're
gonna take here
uh who sees the easy way for uh for
white to just be crushing
in this position crushing positional
edge here
so always be on the lookout for
combinations like these when things are
in flux in the center the idea is going
to be
we want to keep the center in such a way
where our pieces have a lot of squares
and our opponent's pieces don't really
have a good squares
easier said than done sometimes
neil in the chat says e5 looks like a
good move and i think this is sort of
the wrong direction
um no e5 is taking away squares from our
pieces right
you know we want this knight to be able
to look at these squares we want the
rook to be able to breathe
we want this bishop to be able to see
maybe
yeah so let's start with ed5 so i think
this is uh sort of a must right we want
to open
this diagonal first of all open the e4
square
open these squares open this diagonal
so black takes back and then you said
knight takes d4
and it's true that our pieces have good
squares here but i think the problem is
that our opponent's pieces are also
going to have good squares right the
center just gets totally blown up
so there's actually something better in
this position
yeah that's exactly right so we go c5 oh
and so many arrows but the point is
this bishop is on a good diagonal we can
bring this bishop and queen
to a good diagonal this knight is coming
to a good square by force
um and this knight we don't really care
about um
but actually it can come out to f3 after
knight d4 and uh
help support our attack in the meantime
we've actually deprived black of some
pretty important squares
namely the d5 square is a really really
important square
that black just doesn't have access to
because the pawn is in the way
uh and so this is just going to be a big
edge for for white as well
now the good news for magnus here is
that
um you can actually still maintain the
balance more or less
um you just have to find this move
knight e4
and after knight e4 it turns out that
there's not really an easy way for
whites to to maintain an edge here i
think if
it takes on d5
okay i'm already forgetting my prep here
but okay so if d takes e5 then we simply
take on d2
and take on c4 um so black's not super
concerned about
quote unquote losing this pawn on e5
and if c takes d5 i guess this one is
slightly more complex
but i think we're just able to take on
d2 we're not worried about this
variation
um oh and that's the end of the game for
you but
we'll we'll get to that later we'll get
to that later
yeah obviously everybody saw
that coming so we got to b4 here and we
were looking at d5 c4
knight e4 um so the cd5 takes here and
after takes back we're just going to be
able to take
and again the whole center is going to
kind of blow up here um
and in this variation actually white is
probably losing
because uh we're just losing a pawn um
so i think ideas like c4 ideas
like take and then c4 take and then c4
um all these different ideas we're kind
of scaring magnus a little bit you know
this is sort of uh
not the most common idea in the
in the italian uh this bishop b4 and
bishop b2 idea to start pressuring the
center
um so what's the point what what can you
actually learn from this game well
the point is that's um sometimes
you know when your opponent has an idea
like d5 it's
there's not really a good way to just
prevent it outright
especially in these e4 e5 positions
where both players are
really fighting for the center sometimes
the best way to play against it
is to prepare your pieces for the
opening of the position
you can't really stop your opponent from
ripping open the center
but you can put your pieces on the best
square as possible
so that you can give your opponent
problems once the position does open up
and that's exactly what sc punko does
here with b4
and then bishop b2 so just always be on
the lookout
um if you can't kind of calculate your
way
to uh you know an advantage for you like
d take c5 isn't getting us anywhere
this queen b3 move uh was giving me
problems
but um you know it's sort of the wrong
direction or queen is here to defend our
e4 pawn
um and so these concrete things aren't
really getting us anywhere so what we
need to do
is just keep improving our pieces locate
our worst piece
find out how to improve it and then uh
we'll be better suited
for the opening up of the position now
what happened in the game
is even worse for magnus than uh than
that i think white might have a slight
edge
in those those d5 positions but nothing
too crazy
instead magnus plays this move a5
uh and i think this is just a bad move
basically
um so a5 how should white respond
our opponent is attacking our opponent
on b4 it's it's terrifying honestly
yeah just b5 we don't really want to
just
um let it sit because we want to be able
to capture with the pawn
on d4 so just b5
and the problem now for magnus is this
position is very very different
than the position i i kind of showed a
little bit ago
in the position i showed a little bit
ago we saw this bishop on b6 and this
pawn back on c7
and there i was saying black is is kind
of doing okay but here
black definitely is not doing okay
and who can tell me why why isn't black
doing okay here
what's the big difference
yeah and and that's actually the the
main point here so
uh white is able to open the b file sort
of uh
whenever he wants and this is why the
position is so bad
for black usually in these yoko pianos
it's not a huge deal
that white has a little bit of extra
space on the queen side
but here it's a lot more important
because the easiest way
to use a space advantage is to open
things up
on the side of the board where you have
more space
why is that well when you have more
space in the position
then you can much more easily organize
your pieces
to uh to attack weaknesses than your
opponent can to defend their weaknesses
so in this case black is going to have
kind of a myriad of weaknesses
on the queen's side and white is very
easily going to be able
to maneuver the pieces to put some
pressure on them
in the meantime you know with so such
limited space to work with back here
uh black isn't really going to be able
to defend those very effectively
um so at this point already i think i
think magnus is in quite a bit of
trouble
um he continued down with bishop b6
um by the way it's a little bit too late
to go for something like queen
e7 rook d8 and try to play d5 still
because at this point i think white is
just going to play this move
um c4 and the difference now is that
we're not so worried about this knight
coming to e5 because again
we're just ripping things open on the
queen's side and uh black is going to be
in in quite a bit of trouble like 95
here for example
maybe we do play this f4 move no we
definitely don't play that f4 move
but uh you can kind of see the point
right we're pressuring over here
we're able to put on some pressure here
our knight can come to f5 now
and uh things are getting quite scary
for black
um so instead magnus plays bishop b6 and
that's how you can really tell
that uh things have not gone according
to plan for magnus carlsen
right he goes c6 bishop c7 with the idea
of going a5 bishop b6
you know not not so good not so good uh
so the question now
is how do we take our space advantage
and turn it into something concrete
i kind of told you we want to look for
the right moment to open things up on
the b
file and attack black's weaknesses but
how do we
how do we find that right moment
so the key this game is to use the space
advantage
big advantage in space that's why
esapeco is better
uh i would consider
yeah and and that's actually exactly
right we don't want to start with rook a
to b1 because this move might like be
annoying
um but bishop a3 first is exactly what
what essie panko does
and the point now is we're just we are
clearing the path on the b
file we're going to put a rook there and
then we're going to take on c6
when black isn't ready for it magnus
tries this move queen c7
essaypenco is a concern just goes with
rook to b1
and now magnus is actually the one who
gets a little impatient here and plays
c takes b5 and after this move i think
black is
uh pretty close to just busted and this
move is is not so good
um but the bad news for magnus is i mean
if
if you sort of just continue
nonchalantly then
it's not really going to help uh
for example here let's say uh
i don't know let's just say like rook c1
for example to
sort of keep the balance over here you
run out of moves pretty quickly as black
like i guess you can play rook b1
i'm going to start to double up though
and you're really going to have problems
down down this b file in in the very
very near future
um like let's say you pass for example
h5 or something king h7
uh even now i i might be ready to take
come here
and it's tough to deal it's tough to
deal with all these threats
knight c4 is coming as well and white's
pieces are just
better prepared for the opening of the
position you know i have more space
so i can double my rooks so what magnus
does instead
is he forces the issue with uh c takes
b5
but i think his calculation here just
wasn't quite uh
on point so after bishop takes b5
of course we want to keep the b file
open and we want to play with tempo
whenever possible
we get rick to c8 and magnus i think was
expecting that his counter play against
the c3 pawn might be enough to get him
back in this game
uh so how do we deal how do we deal with
these problems that magnus has given us
he's only the world champion
um no so d5 is the right idea um the
problem here is if you just simply
defend your pawn or something
um you're pinned on the c file e takes
is is uh not too hard to find so d5
first is
is great we just want to gain a tempo on
this bishop and give us time to do
something
um bishop d7 and now
knight here i think does actually um
of course the problem is going to be
this move i guess you're saying
we can take this is that what you wanted
all right
all right we didn't calculate anything
but that's okay maybe you can take this
guy even
but uh now estee panko finds better here
you don't need to find all that
craziness um scpenko simply plays bishop
f1
and sort of calls magnus's bluff here if
you take on c3
i think the simplest is probably just to
take take now both bishops are attacks
but i can save mine
and uh you've got problems here
uh you've got problems here i have a
problem here
but you know your three problems are
sort of more important than my one
um and i think sepenko is just kind of
crushing here down the b
file again when you have extra space
things tend to be good for you on the
side of the board where you have extra
space especially when things open up
so just bishop f1 and magnus plays this
slightly weak move
rook a to b8 just sort of trying to
defend
um here already though i mean the
position is is pretty pretty bad
for uh for magnus now eric's idea does
come into play with knight c4
this is just the way to add more
pressure and
kind of out of nowhere um it's very
difficult for magnus to defend a5 to
defend
d6 to defend b7 the only move to stay in
the game
is bishop c5 and now scpenko simply
captures captures
and goes rook b6 and already this is
sort of the the end of the game for you
know most normal players
magnus of course puts up like horribly
strong resistance all the time
because he's magnus carlson but uh you
just can't deal with these three
separate problems all at the same time
in in the meantime i mean
what is black doing he's just just
defending
um so d6 is attacked twice due to black
space disadvantage it's very difficult
to defend the only move is 98
no other legal way to defend this this
pawn aside from
you know rook c6 which is not so good uh
so 98
we just double up on the b file not a
hard move defines
queen c7 we triple up on the b file not
a hard move defines
uh queen back to d8 uh you know ben
feingold
setting up for the next game as always
uh
and then i mean this pawn is hanging
this pawn is hanging and this pawn is
hanging
like not only can black not deal with
all three problems but he can't deal
with any of them
like nothing he can't defend anything
and that's just again
because of his lack of space essie penco
finds a good move which is queen a3
not taking any of the pawns but just
getting ready to take on a5
uh queen b6 you take on d6 take on d6
take bring the other rook into b6 and uh
this position is something like plus
five like it's
it's real bad real real bad at this
point
um at this point uh magnus just plays f6
and then essie panko plays like a very
bad move in the form of queen to a1
um much simpler i think is to just push
this pawn forward
magnus can try to take it but like you
have very serious problems with this
bishop on d7 like bishop b5 for example
is a good move and
not not so clear how magnus is going to
get out of this one
but okay queen a1 instead doesn't really
spoil too much
knight h8 is the big re-routing maneuver
for magnus
but at this point sepenko just keeps up
the pressure and manages to to convert
bishop e5 just to give his rooks a
little bit more freedom on these light
squares
and v6 is important otherwise you lose
that rook
queen c5 take queen c4
and we're going to kind of zoom through
towards the end of the game here you
know
black's other weak other weaknesses
start to fall and you know essie pence a
good enough player to keep track of his
own weaknesses in the meantime
uh queen takes c3 take and white is up
two pawns here which is enough rook c4
just a5 if you take here
i go a6 rook f8 is magnus's idea
but now knight h4 and again if you take
here i think
knight g6 is the problem and again sort
of everything is
everything is falling uh knight d8
is magnuson's response we get rookie
seven
uh magnus takes off the rook f3 and i
mean this is
this is just sad this d pawn is too
strong
d-pawn is too strong g4 takes some space
g6
is how magnus tries to break out you
really can't move any of your pieces
otherwise
so g6 good enough try
we enter this sort of forcing variation
knight g6 rook d6
take take and then estipanko doesn't
have to work too hard
to find the win here he goes rook h8
transpose him to the king and pawn end
game
and then everybody calculated this one
from five miles away
but uh what's the cleanest win here
what's the cleanest win for white
one last test for you
all right brian wants to play f4 i think
all the moves win
this might be the least clean um
he's gonna take go kingy six
and here you definitely still win this
end game so
maybe it's all good maybe it's all good
um i like essie pence way the best
which is he goes g5 and the point now
is that after takes black is still going
to come after a pawn on the queen's
slide
but we can go king d4 get in front of
the pawn and still promote ours
i think no king d4 is ridiculous
uh king d6 is what essie punko played
and it's the best
um and the point now as everybody saw
from a mile away
is that after queens queens um
your king is in a bad spot
and this queen is dying
so g5 and you just gotta calculate a
little bit to uh to get to the end
originally i thought his idea was going
to be to go king d4
with the point being we're in time to
stop the pawn if you do this
but then i sort of realized that uh
maybe this isn't so simple if uh if i go
king b6 here so
no need to deal with all that you just
do the calculation and get to the end
so what happened this game let's recap a
little bit
it all sort of happened back here in the
opening and that's why i spent so much
time back here
in these italian positions there is so
much going on there's so many different
options
for both players and it can be really
difficult to
find good moves like b4 and bishop b2
but that's what essepenco does to to
beat up on magnus carlsen here
so what's the point to take away the
point to take away is that
in any given position especially in
these e45 positions
oftentimes the best thing you can do is
just identify your worst piece
and improve it in this case magnus
played a slightly offbeat line
chose not to move the a-pawn brought the
bishop back to c7 very early
and essie penco realized maybe i can
take advantage of that to improve my
bishop
and that simple idea is what sort of
snowballed
into this game getting out of control
for magnus carlsen
so questions on this game it's a very
dense game to start with
um lots going on here but i i think we
kind of got through it start to finish
any questions
all right everybody loves the gioco
pianissimo
everybody loves it okay with that let's
get on to the main event for the past
for the last 17 minutes of the class
everybody wants to talk about
magnus carlsen getting destroyed by yon
duda in the tie breaks of the
semi-finals so i figured i better go
over this game
because even though yan broke my heart
and played the sicilian rather than the
cairo
it ended up just looking like a very
very good caro khan so i want to talk
about the sicilian variation a little
bit
and about what went wrong for uh for
magnus here
so we do get a do get a sicilian magnus
plays knight f3
d6 and of course we get the bishop b5
checkline so magnus has been doing this
for for quite a while i think um
of course this is game two of the rapid
tie breaks in their match
setting uh and magnus drew
round one with the black pieces so he's
trying to put on a little bit of
pressure
but it's not like he's in a must win or
anything so he's just playing chess
we get bishop d7 by duda
this is probably i think the the safest
line for black you can play knight d7
and try to go kind of crazy over here
play knight c6 as well the bishop d7 is
sort of the move that says
you know i don't believe in your bishop
e5 idea i'm gonna keep it simple
and we can trade these bishops if you
like
so bishop takes e7 queen takes d7
castles
knight f6 and then i really
don't like this variation um for white
it's a very common variation so it can't
be that bad
but i simply just don't like it for
white because what we get
is after queen e2 knight c6 c3
e6 d4 we're going to trade c
pawns i get to go d5 now after e5 knight
e4
it looks like a very good caro khan it's
a carol khan where uh i'm not getting
checkmated
it's carocon because the light squared
bishops are off the board and the c
file's open
and i'm just i'm not even close to
getting checkmated i even have this nice
active night out here
on uh on e4 now in the game magnus
chooses the simplest variation which is
knight d2
just trading off this knight and then
here already i
i mean i think black has no problems and
i as a kerocon player myself i tend to
prefer these positions
so what could magnus do instead well
magnus could not play this
dumb bishop b5 opening but aside from
that
uh c4 is apparently a very common way to
play here
and you get more moratzi binds type
positions
that being said light squared bishops
off the board it shouldn't be too scary
for black
um and even here i think something like
rookie one
and sort of testing with uh something
like b3
would be a little bit of a better way to
play
c3 here as well though is is perfectly
fine
and we would end up in kind of similar
positions here
with with e5 i just i just don't really
like this variation for white to be
honest
you know it just doesn't feel like much
let's get back to the game though
so this is the opening variation that
magnus carlsen has
chosen i think duda was a prepared a
little bit beyond this point still
but uh let's stop here and figure out
how we're going to organize our pieces
so we've played through the opening and
now how do we continue
so first and foremost we have to develop
this bishop and bishop e7
is a likely candidate and that is the
normal move
dude instead chooses bishop b4 i think
both are fine
duda is happy to draw with the black
pieces though so he's like yeah okay
let's trade pieces
uh magnus plays bishop f4 keeping the
bishops on the board
now we castle and queen d3
so now okay i mean it this time let's
pause
and figure out what's going on in this
position how do we organize our pieces
and what is white trying to do what is
black trying to do what is white trying
to do
so there's sort of a balance that we
have to keep here
with uh with the black pieces
so what do we want to do with black
yeah as always you want to play on the
side where you have more space
or the side where your pawns point
because that's where you have more space
this case our pawns are pointing to the
queen's side we have more space over
there
we want to get our rooks on the c file
uh challenge the c file invade on the c
file maybe bring our knight into a
square like c4
and you know potentially shove some
pawns down the board on the queen side
as well this is what we'd like to do
but what's stopping us from doing that
what's stopping us from just going
you know rook c8 you know a5 b5
a6 b5 knight a5
yeah if if we get too ambitious and just
kind of go wild over here
we got to start looking out for moves
like knight g5
if we have to play g6 and then uh i mean
let's just say knight back here
and bishop here and
it can get scary it can get scary on the
king's side if if we let it happen
so for that reason um duda starts with
with bishop e7 here
so it kind of seems like we both wasted
some time in the opening
moving our bishop multiple times but
both sides wasted the time so it's not
not a huge deal
so bishop b7 first and now a3
so trying to stop any piece from landing
on on
b4 perhaps so now the question is
you know we probably want to bring a
rook to the c file but
which rook which rook do we use
so there should be an intuitive one but
then because i'm asking
you're probably gonna ask you're gonna
you're gonna guess the other one right
so so what's the intuitive rook to move
over
oh god that's not the intuitive one at
all
yeah so i would intuitively i would want
to move the f
rook over to the c file now why is that
well it's because i want to play on the
queen side
maybe i want to open up the b file later
and i want to have this a rook over here
to help with that
but speaking from experience sometimes
you want to have this rook over here to
help defend your king a little bit
so maybe that's why eric just intuits
the correct move
rook a to c8 um in sororic a toc it is
the move
that that due to place i don't think
it's a massive deal in this position
but just in general um it's nice to have
this rook on f8 sometimes to help defend
your king
uh rarely you know if some craziness
happens
the f file might uh might open up and it
could be good to have a rook here
obviously we are a ways away from
anything like that happening but we're
okay to see
um white plays this move g3 now and
again this is why i
i just don't really like this variation
for white it feels like the king side
attack isn't really going anywhere
and black more or less has a free hand
just to play on the queen's side
so knight a5 by duda and positions
technically just dead equal here but i
think um
i think i would much prefer to be
playing with black
what's the idea what's the idea with g3
i think
the idea is very deep it's making left
for the king um i really think that's
all that's that's going on here
um white can also try to play h4
uh you know sometimes though you want to
have the pawn on g3 first so your knight
isn't stuck to
the h4 pawn so yeah shoring up the h4
square perhaps and making love for the
king
uh risk says is this a caro khan
structure
and yeah basically you know we got here
from the sicilian
but this is just a very good carrot con
in my opinion
um you know what's the difference well
black played c5 in one turn
and then uh you know white slowly but
surely
struck back in the center so rook a to
c8
then we get g3 by white again you know
it
looks like a mysterious move makes love
for the king and shores up the structure
for for an eventual h4
uh knight a5 is very very logical for
duda
and then magnus plays this move b3
so b3 is a a pretty big concession by
magnus carlsen generally when in these
positions when they play a3
they would like to be going b4 um but in
this position i i think that's
uh magnus simply didn't like the move a5
now i could be wrong here i didn't prep
this one super far
but i think a5 is just causing too many
problems for white
you know your only idea is is going to
be to play
b5 or i guess theoretically something
like rook b1 but let's say b5
and here black is just on the file first
and things are going to get awkward
going to get awkward for uh for white
so no b4 and instead b3
so now uh dude has already made a lot of
progress on the queen's side white has
played a3 and b3 which really softens up
both these pawns and some squares on the
queen side
so how do we continue now how do we
continue on the queen side
giving white problems
and julian in the chat says my boy in
reference
to yon duda i believe that's due to them
sharing a middle name which i will now
attempt to pronounce
live on stream
kirschtoff kristoff kristoff
there you go christoph final answer part
of his first name
yeah he's okay it's jan krishnaf is
is his name as ben simon correctly
points out
uh julian it's just his middle name
great wolf says it's okay to butcher it
i think people have done worse
people have done better but i think
they've done worse
okay randy just says don't pronounce the
kr just just off
good enough for me back to business
though
thank you brian how do we pressure these
pawns
okay yeah you can double the rooks
white's gonna challenge you on the
on the file like likely
maybe we need to rewrite our knife
yeah i mean eventually we need to
reroute this night but um
uh jan schistoff
comes up with a very uh very direct way
to put on pressure yeah what's up eric
a6
yeah that's that's exactly right a6 uh
preparing queen b5
is an important idea here that jan comes
up with
and the point is we're simply pressuring
this pawn on b3
and it can be quite awkward to defend
i don't think we want to move our knight
away just yet
and the reason for that is if white ever
plays b4
it's nice to be ready with this move
knight to c4
so queen c6 is actually how uh
yawn starts uh and the point here i
think is that after rook c1
and queen v6 is also a good idea but the
same idea is to get to the b
file right so queen c6 to start we get
bishop d2
queen b6 rook b1 and now
uh eric's idea of a6 queen b5 comes into
play
and it uh it's pretty nasty what yan is
doing to magnus here he's just sort of
bit by
bit taking away all the squares on the
queen side again
it's easier to play on the side where
you have more space the same idea
king g2 by magnus and now before queen
b5 we do have to solve the problem of
our knight
so we get knight back to c6 rook e1 and
queen b5
uh this is not actually going to be a
very comfortable structure for white at
all
um we have too much pressure coming down
the a file
and i don't think white's going to be
very happy with that so we get queen
back to b1 instead
and now now finally now that we've
locked up a lot of white's pieces
yan just doubles on the c file
and continues with a5
okay we get rook h1 a4 forcing more
weaknesses into white's camp
b4 and okay h6
a little bit of a slower move just to
stop any ideas
for white here knight g5 is never really
working
just go g6 and you're way too slow
on the king's side you know worst case
my king can run
so bishop e3 instead now knight back to
a7
and you know jan has has kind of just
been super professional about it he just
uh forces magnus to weaken all his
squares
takes over the c file and now he's going
to bring his knight into b5 and then the
game
we get queen e2 queen c4 and knight b5
and uh all of a sudden white is just
kind of lost here
and we're running short on time so i'm
gonna sort of zoom through the rest of
the game in a minute
but this was the meat of the chess game
basically
you know magnus gets nowhere on the
king's side
and then all of a sudden yawn just takes
over on the queen's light so i want to
make sure we have a good understanding
of what happened here because really it
was
in these few moves where b3 was played
a6 this queen b5 idea came into play
and all of a sudden it's it's just yan
who is pushing for this
entire game here um so questions about
hot how young managed to take over
okay i mean it's he just makes it look
easy right uh but the important things
to remember
this game are you know target the points
that your opponent has weakened
um in in their structure right a3 b3
makes all these squares weak
and that's where yon starts targeting
first with queen c6 to b6
and then queen b5 taking over more
squares
and then after doubling we see him go a4
provoking b for
weakening this pivotal c4 square as well
now according to the engine white is
still technically doing okay here if you
find
some concrete ideas like uh rook b2
giving this guy up for like rook a2 and
then
upon here and things are going to
liquify a little bit
but uh magnus of course doesn't find
those ideas in the game
goes b4 and now it's just worse for the
rest of the game
all right so let's continue on pressing
forward
we get knight b5 rook d3
and dion takes his time about it brings
his bishop into play as well
just targeting all of the weaknesses in
white's camp
and sort of helpless to do anything
about it bishop e3 now knight c3
is good you get queen b5 rook c2 knight
e4
one trait of rooks and now after rook to
d1
uh there's a very strange decision by by
jan here
i think he should just take this and put
his rook on c3
and just be crushing you have to defend
this guy
and then i don't even rook b3 here
and uh this pawn is not long for this
world um
but instead yan chooses rook c4 keeping
the the queens on the board
we get knight d2 take take queen c6
and uh even even here this is just very
very tough
for magnus and after queen c4 that the
deal is is more or less
uh well should have been more or less
sealed
black is just crushing with this very
very active rook
now because magnus is too strong he
manages to create problems with d5
which we're going to zoom right through
here um so d5 and magnus's idea is to go
rook d2
now the simplest here is actually the
nice move rook a3
and then rook d3 when two passive pawns
are going to be enough
to win the game instead though jan
misses rook a3 goes rook d3 right away
and after that we get this sort of
obscene bishop end game
which maybe robert hungaski will go over
in his endgame class to follow
maybe not though uh we don't have time
to go into all the details here
but basically there's a lot of back and
forth magnus comes up with this nice
defensive idea
playing hing takes d3 um you're not
able to actually take this pawn on f4
due to a nice breakthrough idea
of going g6 and e6 e7
when uh it's actually white who might be
winning the game
so instead we see g6 by jan uh
now threatening king takes uh here
maybe uh unclear sometimes uh so we get
bishop back to e3
bishop back to c7 and now magnus plays
b5 and this is sort of the beginning of
the end
magnus sort of had to find this clever
bishop c5 move here
and or just repeating with
king d4 so magnus short on the clock
wasn't able to calculate whether or not
he was actually okay in the sun game
turns out this is a draw but
understandably
he wasn't able to calculate that super
super quickly and he also missed this
nice trick of bishop c5
now the problem is if you take here i'm
just going bishop d6
takes takes isn't going to get it done
and bishop d8
now the problem for you is that this
move is checked so
missing both those ideas he plays b5 now
all of a sudden
black has a plan for improvement he goes
bishop d8
we repeat a couple times bishop b7
and then um magnus misses his last
chance to draw
could have gone bishop d4 looks very
very scary
but manages to keep the balance here
with some ideas of king b6
instead he goes bishop back to c1 now
after bishop c3
it's actually going to be game over here
there's no way
for white to stop d4 d3 d2 you might
think you can do it
with bishop e3 but you're gonna get
checked and
just destroyed anyways in the game
magnus came up with b6 himself
and after uh d4 king uh
two c4 king d7 bishop e3 was his big
trick
hoping for takes and takes
but now um jan just picks up the a3 pawn
and this is not a pretty end game for
magnus
takes takes and here magnus carlsen
resigns
and throws away his chances of winning
the 2021
world cup how dare he resign um
of course this is just dud lost he's
going to take all these pawns and
yanduda advances
to the finals of the world cup so tough
tournament for magnus we analyzed two of
his toughest losses
and uh he did have some good games this
tournament as well one really
interesting queen sack
but a very chaotic tournament for magnus
carlson definitely
uh so with that that's all i have for
you guys tonight it's time for me to
turn over the microphone
to robert hugoski with insane in the end
game be sure to stick around for that
and be sure to tune into that online as
well as always my name is caleb denby
thank you very much for watching and i
will see you next time
[Music]
you